One of the biggest dangers, listen to me,
one of the biggest dangers that can stunt
your entrepreneurial spirit in life is when
you grow up and you start hitting plateaus,
misfortunes, failures, breakups.
Anything that breaks your heart at some point,
we go from being these emotional creatures
where we're childlike and we play and everything
is possible and we dream, and fantasize, and
we become too logical.
When that happens, the fire, imagine the fire
is lit, where you can light up the world with
your ideas, it gets turned off.
And then everything's wiped out, when it comes
down to creation.
See, the reason why today in this video I
want to talk about this because, look, if
you think about the greatest entrepreneurs
and you study them, you will see, they may
be 45 years old, and age-wise, we could call
it an "older person," or whatever you want
to call them, but their spirit is childlike.
Not childish.
Not silly.
Not immature - childlike.
Today I'm going to talk about why 11 reasons
why the best entrepreneurs are childlike.
And I'm doing this episode today from a very
significant room, very special room.
We rented out the entire week at the castle.
And if you've never been to the Oheka Castle,
every year I take a group of executives.
This year it was 60 of them.
And we go to different places.
We've gone to Italy, we've gone to Dubai,
we've gone to different places around the
world, that we do this with, and we will rent
out nice places.
This year we decided to rent out Oheka Castle.
Tigran found this place.
It's based in Long Island, right outside of
New York.
It's 109,000 square feet.
It was built between 1914 - 1919.
It took five years to build this place.
It's got 126 bedrooms.
It is now a hotel.
And you can buy it right now if you want to
make an offer for $150 million.
I was with the owner last night.
Just a beautiful property.
And one of the rooms, the one we're in right
now is called the Chaplin room.
Because many of the people have partied here,
the Rockefellers, The Clintons, Trumps, presidents,
celebrities, Hollywood, Jordan, athletes,
Chaplin, you know, the Great Gatsby movie
was inspired.
the author of, Fitzgerald, when he wrote Great
Gatsby, he looked at a building, it was this
building, the Oheka Castle, and he wrote the
book, based on this property that he saw.
This room was Chaplin's room.
You see Chaplin all over the place.
If you read the book Art of Seduction by Robert
Greene, there's a whole section of how Chaplin
by being this childlike figure seduced so
many women and audiences, where people would
watch him and they were fascinated by his
spirit and he was so attractive.
People loved him.
And then eventually, this guy's career takes
off because he's childlike, he's creative,
all this other stuff.
By doing all these silent movies, what do
they call them?
The movies that had no noise?
Silent films they would do.
Then all of a sudden, movies go from silent
films, to now there's sound in it and then
he didn't want to adjust.
Because he liked doing the silent movies more.
He didn't want to adjust.
So this guy went from being so creative to
all of a sudden being so logical.
And his career didn't end well for this guy.
How does that even happen?
See, it doesn't matter how old you are right
now.
You may say, Oh, I'm the most creative person
I'll ever be.
Anyone can turn off the fire at any point
if you don't pay attention to this part.
So let's get right into it.
11 qualities.
11 reasons why the best entrepreneurs are
childlike.
#1: They're constantly speaking the dream
language.
See, my boys, I have two boys, and they're
always talking the dream language.
The other day, always, it's always some kind
of a dream we're talking about here.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Dad, look at the stars!
Dad, you know, hey, look over there.
Hey Pop, did you see Santa Claus?!
It's Santa Claus!
Did you see?
It's always this fantasy world they're living
in.
It's this dream world they're living in.
And as adults, we become too good to believe
in Santa Claus.
We become too good to believe in dreams.
We become too good to believe in fairy tales.
We become too good to believe in all these
things that are possible, and they don't.
And by the way, neither do great entrepreneurs.
Great entrepreneurs still fantasize.
Great entrepreneurs still dream.
Great entrepreneurs still think things are
possible.
Do you know great entrepreneurs, most people,
if you hang out with great entrepreneurs that
are constantly creating things, if you hang
around them for too long, do you know what
you would say?
"This guy's a little bit off."
[chuckle] This guy's completely.
. did you see what he was saying?
He's crazy!
Was he smoking something?
Was he drunk?
Because what he was talking about earlier
was absolutely insane.
I think he's got psychological problems.
The world would call some of the best entrepreneurs
in the world that view the world in a complete
different way psychologically off.
Because the rest of the world at some point
[snap] lost the flame because they became
too logical and they're still in the imaginative
mode and they can't fully understand why they
think the way they do.
Because they're childlike.
Just like kids are always saying, dad, what
if we could do this.
Imagine if we could do this, great entrepreneurs
do it as well.
#2:They come to you with different approaches
until you say yes.
They come to you with different approaches
For instance, Hey, Dad, can I have some chocolate?
No, daddy, you can't have chocolate right
now.
They go, and they come back.
But daddy, I need some chocolate.
Who says you need?
You want.
No, no, I need some chocolate, Daddy!
Why do you need some chocolate?
Because I need it!
Why do you need it?
Because I NEED it, Daddy!
And then okay, that doesn't work.
So then they go and come back.
And they strategize with their two brothers
and they come back.
Daddy, Daddy, I love you so much, Daddy.
I love you so much.
Can I give you a kiss on the cheek?
And you forgot about it.
You completely forgot about it.
They haven't forgotten about what they want.
They have one outcome.
They want that chocolate.
And they come and they kiss you.
And they hug you and tell you how much they
love you.
And then they say, Daddy, can I have some
chocolate?
And you say, "I'll get you some chocolate.
C'mon, let's go get some chocolate."
It's the same exact thing.
It's like going back and negotiating with
somebody and you constantly go back with a
different way of negotiating until they say
yes.
See, entrepreneurs are childlike.
Just like kids come up to us and renegotiating
and we don't even know about it.
And they just simply change their approach.
And they change their approach and they change
their approach until you and I like suckers
say what?
Yes, I'll do business with you, son.
Let's get you the chocolate."
#3 is they persuade emotionally instead of
logically.
See, let me explain what I mean by that, they
persuade emotionally, not logically.
Adults think.
Children feel.
Let me say it again.
Adults think.
Children feel.
They feel things.
Right?
Like have you noticed when kids go in a room
and they look at an adult and they kind of
checking them out and they're feeling how
they are.
And they're kind of like not getting too close,
and all this other stuff, and they're kind
of.
. . because they're feeling.
And not just thinking.
They're feeling.
So everything is emotion.
We age, and everything becomes logical.
No, this is too this.
This is too that.
And we become these logical robots.
People are worried about robots taking over
the world.
Let's face it.
People are becoming robots.
Forget about robots.
People are robots nowadays.
You don't need to worry about robots.
Most people have become robots, because they're
living so logically, instead of tying their
emotion to something they want to do and going
after it, not saying I cannot pull this off.
#4: too innocent to understand what's impossible.
Too innocent to understand it's impossible.
Hey, we can do this.
Why not, Daddy?
We're going to go on the moon one day.
You know, we're going to go do this one day.
Daddy, you know what I want to do?
What do you want to do?
I want to be a police office.
Why?
So I can arrest the bad T-Rex.
I'm sorry, you want to do what?
I want to be a police officer, Daddy.
My son will say crazy things.
What the heck did this kid just say?
I want to be a police officer because I want
to arrest the T-Rex because the T-Rex sometimes
they fight and they get the smaller dinosaur
and I want to arrest the bad T-Rex.
Where did this idea come from?
It's that movie with dinosaurs in it.
What is that cartoon with dinosaurs in it?
[The Land Before Time?]
No, no, no, the new one.
There's a new cartoon with dinosaurs in it.
It's, you know, the green dinosaur?
Anyway, so there's - what is is called?
The Good Dinosaur!
That's what it's called.
Right?
And then in The Good Dinosaur, there's bad
T-Rexes, so what the heck is this kid talking
about?
When he's sitting there telling me about that
we're going to have these cops that are going
to arrest these T-Rexes and then we're going
to fly on the moon and we're going to live
on the moon and Thomas and Friends, they're
going to get on the train and we're going
to go.
. . where are you going with this?
What are you guys talking about with this?
See, that to you and I may sound crazy.
But you know what's crazy?
Here's what's crazy.
Do you know what is the biggest selling movie
of all time?
Star Wars.
Do you know why?
Because it taps into a certain level of imagination
with you and I that we logically can't go
to.
That we need somebody to take us there, because
we sit there and say, Oh my gosh, what if?
Voom!
What if I could be this guy, this hero, you
know, and all these guys show up and Chewbacca
and all this.
What if we could, oh this would be crazy.
You know why?
We watched that movie.
And it makes billions, trillions as much money
as it makes.
You know why?
Because we want to go there.
We want to go there.
Now at some point when we were six years old,
we were there.
But we left there.
We kind of need to go back there, and get
that fire lit up again.
#5, number five is this, they are extremely
curious.
They're fully curious.
Hey Daddy, what is this, Daddy?
Like this kid will sit there, you know the
thing by the door, what do you call that thing?
[buzzing sound] - Door stopper.
Is that what you call it?
Is it really a door stop?
This kid will sit there he'll just play with
that thing the entire time.
Sometimes I'm thinking he's thinking he's
playing with something else.
Maybe he used to because he's.
. . anyway, let me get back.
So he plays with this thing, the entire time.
He's so proud of it, right?
He plays with this thing.
I'm like, pop, what are you doing?
Then he took it out.
Why is this kid taking it out?
You know the entire time I didn't know you
could take it out.
I'm just watching him and he just goes like
this, he takes it out.
Then he goes and brings another one and takes
it out.
And then he puts a toy inside of it.
So now when we close the door, you know the
whole thing that makes it softer when the
door closes?
It's even softer than it was before.
And you don't even hear it now.
So it doesn't go, tack!
It's softer.
It just goes . . . you don't hear anything.
So how did that happen?
This kid is sitting there messing around with
it until he figured out what he wanted to
do because simply he's curious.
What is this?
Daddy, what is it?
What do you do with this thing, Daddy?
Nonstop, these kids are so curious.
And we lose that level of curiosity as we
age.
#6: they have a reset mentality.
You know what's a reset mentality?
You know, Dylan, this kid Dylan is so charming,
but here's how Dylan is.
Dylan the other day, climbs the couch.
He falls off the couch.
He cries for 13 seconds, then all of a sudden
he goes and he plays LEGO and he completely
forgot about the fall.
It's like reset.
Reset!
This never happened.
Forgot about it.
This quickly [snap].
He completely forgot about it.
You know what we do as adults?
You don't understand what happened man.
What happened?
She broke my heart.
Oh really, yesterday?
No, it was like two years ago, bro, but I'm
still dealing with it.
Are you kidding me bro?
Two years ago?
Reset!
Break up!
She don't exist.
Move on.
You know what I'm saying?
Like reset and move on.
And we don't do it.
Our reset is two years.
Their reset is a half a second.
They just move on.
They're short memory.
There's a benefit for it.
Some of the greatest basketball players, quarterbacks,
the best performers as athletes, they have
a short memory.
It's a very solid strength of shooters.
They used to say Kobe's got the shortest memory
in the NBA.
One time this cat missed 21 shots in a row.
And you know how he shot the 22nd one?
As if he's been making ten in a row.
And then he made it.
You have to have a short memory.
And he's right.
#7: They charm their way into getting anything
they want.
They charm their way into getting anything
They charm.
You know how they charm you?
They'll come to you.
They'll look at you with their eyes.
And they'll do their whole thing with their
eyes.
One of these things.
And they'll smile at you.
Then they'll say stuff to you, and like even,
you know, they know how to do it from early
on.
My daughter right now, she seduces me.
She's six months old.
She looks at me, she goes like this, and then
she kind of looks away like she's not interested.
At six months old, they know how to seduce.
At six months old.
At two and a half years old, three years old,
my son seduces me all the time.
He doesn't even know it.
The way he does it, he looks up at me, he's
about to get a pow pow, and he goes like this,
and he goes like this, and he kind of looks
up at me like that.
I'm so sorry.
And how can you even discipline this kid right
here, right?
And he charms.
They seduce their way into getting whatever
they want.
#8: Their mind never stops.
So let me explain what happens when their
mind never stops.
You know, as we're kids, and we're growing
up, we're being fed so many different experiences
so quickly.
So many new experiences so quickly, that our
mind's going.
. . . so when the mind - let me explain it
this way.
Imagine when you were working out five days
a week.
Okay?
Versus working out once a week.
Which one allows you to build muscles more
often?
Five days a week.
Not once a week.
Our mind stops working five days a week.
It now just works once a week.
Because to us it becomes what?
I'm going to work and here's what I do and
I clock in and this is all I do today and
this is all I do tomorrow.
And our mind is no longer getting new experiences.
It's the same experience it's had for 20 years,
25 years, 30 years, 35 years.
Nothing new's being fed it.
So it's not working at five days a week.
Kids, their brain, muscles, and imagination
work seven days a week, 24/7, it works.
Ours doesn't any more.
You got to get this thing working again, like
you did before.
#9: They learn faster because they make mistakes
faster.
We don't make mistakes fast enough.
Matter of fact, I'm here to tell you, we don't
make enough mistakes.
There's a saying that I have when I work with
my peers, and anybody I'm mentoring.
Any of the executives, any of the staff, any
of the sales people.
I don't mind you making new mistakes.
I do mind old mistakes.
But I don't mind new mistakes.
Matter of fact, make new mistakes faster.
The biggest difference between the bigger
guys and the smaller guys is they make mistakes
much faster than the rest do.
#10: Here's number 10.
Ten is a very simple and unique one.
To most people, as we become adults, life
becomes a job.
It becomes a chore.
Being married is a chore.
Having kids is a chore.
Running a company is a chore.
Becoming an executive is a chore.
To kids, life is purely a game.
They're playing a game 24/7.
So what does that mean?
Do you know what happens if life is a game?
Let me tell you what happens if life is a
game.
If you treat life as a game, you'd be having
a lot more fun with life.
They're having fun.
You say, but Pat, c'mon.
Man, I have a job.
I have to pay the bills, all this other stuff.
So what you have to do that.
Find a new way to have fun with it.
You figure out a way to have fun with it.
You can do that.
We figure out ways to have fun at our office
all the time.
We have to figure out ways to have fun with
our company all the time.
Believe me, this entire team, we're having
fun.
One of the things we're talking about, one
of our guys, we come to the Oheka Castle and
he says, Oh my gosh, rumor has it this place
has ghosts.
Mario put a note underneath saying, "you are
not alone."
He puts a newspaper clipping under the door,
and it says, "you are not alone."
And this guy is a guy that's completely freaked
out about ghosts.
And Mario, Mr. Prankster, is famous for pranking
people, he puts this thing under the door
and it says you are not alone.
And we talked about ghosts all morning today
because he's concerned about ghosts.
Two guys are very concerned about ghosts.
What happened there?
We're here for a gathering.
And this is a very serious gathering.
But you always got to find some time to have
fun because it's a game.
And by the way, those who learn to play this
game the best and have fun at it, always win.
They just always win.
No matter how much people made fun of Michael
on how bad he wanted to win, Michael was the
guy, when Kevin Garnett was a rookie basketball
player coming in, Mike goes switches Kevin
Garnett's shorts from a double extra-large
to an extra small shorts.
So Kevin Garnett was 6' 11" was putting these
shorts.
Can you imagine how tight these shorts are?
These are baseball players that put, you know,
they fire up the cleats of their teammates
and they tie their shoe laces underneath together
so that when they stand up and they fall.
If you learn how to play this game and have
fun at it, you'll be very, very good at it,
and you'll actually enjoy it, and you'll be
able to do it a lot longer than burning out
too soon.
And last but not least, last but not least.
Childlike mindset.
Entrepreneurs have a childlike mindset.
They are always in creation mode.
They're always in creation mode.
They're constantly creating.
LEGOs.
When we were kids in Iran, LEGOs were like
the rich man's toys.
Rich kids' toys.
If you played with LEGOs, in Iran, you were
rich.
That's how we viewed you.
Who has LEGOs?
No one's got LEGOs, right?
A LEGO you must be very wealthy.
You must have a millionaire family.
My son, Tico, will take these LEGOs and say,
"Dad, I made a ship.
Dad, I made a plane.
Dad, I made this.
Dad, look what I made.
I made a boat.
Dad, look it this over here.
Dad, look what I made over here.
It's constant creation mode.
The other day, the other day at our house,
one of the biggest blinds falls.
Biggest blind falls.
These guys, Tico and Dylan, I keep hearing
like something's going on over there.
And they're walking with this eight-foot blind,
a three-year-old and a four-year-old, they're
carrying blinds.
I'm like, where are these guys going with
this thing?
So I'm just trying to let them go and do their
thing, but followed them to see what they're
doing.
So, they're walking.
They take this big blind into the toy room,
from the top angle, it's eight feet.
And you know what they're doing?
From the top, they're putting these cars that
go down and just fly up in the basket, and
they're trying to see if they can make it
in the basket that's three feet off the top.
And then you know what I do?
I say, this is actually pretty fun, and I
start playing the game with them.
Because they're constantly in creation mode.
And the more you stay in creation mode, the
more you can keep yourself there, if you can,
that's what the great entrepreneurs do.
They stay in creation mode.
Creation mode keeps creating more things.
If you don't create, you lose the muscle of
creating.
So there are a lot of other things I can talk
about about why the best entrepreneurs in
the world tend to be extremely childlike,
but I've got 11 of them here for you to go
through.
So here's what I want to do with you.
I've you've got any other ones you would add
to the list, comment on the bottom.
If you've got any questions or thoughts, also
comment on the bottom.
Mario, give us our pillow here that made it.
Oh, that's a nice throw.
What a distance thrower, right?
You are like two feet away from me.
Hey, if you haven't subscribed, subscribe
to this channel on the bottom here.
Our goal is to get to one million subs by
the end of 2017, to get to one million subs
with Valuetainment by the end of 2017, because
we believe pound for pound, there are a lot
of motivational YouTube channels out there.
There are a lot of channels that keep regurgitating
the same exact thing, with another different
place and another different vlog and another
different platform.
Here, you come to Valuetainment for one reason.
We're going to show you how to do things on
this channel.
How to.
How to become more creative.
How to hire.
How to fire.
How to put business plans together.
How to become a better culture in your office.
Everything's on how for you to make your business
better for free, so you need to subscribe
to the channel if you haven't yet, because
we need you.
We need you to help us to get to a million
subs.
We need you to help us get to a million subs.
We just recently crossed over 150,000 subs.
We got 850 more to go by the end of 2017 to
get to a million subs.
And by the way, some of you guys say that's
crazy or childlike.
We believe it's possible.
We think we can get to a million subs.
Do you?
If you do, help us get there.
Thanks so much for watching everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.